Gardening is my graffiti.
I grow my art.
Ibeautify lawns, parkways.
I use the garden, the soil,
like it's a piece of cloth,
and theplants and the trees,
that's my embellishment for that cloth.
I live in a food desert.
So meand my group,
L.A. Green Grounds,
we got together and we
started planting my food forest,
fruittrees, you know, the whole nine.
I have witnessed my garden
become a tool for the education,
atool for the transformation
of my neighborhood.
To change the community,
you have to changethe
composition of the soil.
We are the soil.
I want us all to become
ecolutionary renegades,
gangstas, gangsta gardeners.
What I'm talking about is
putting people to work,
and getting kids off the street,
and letting them know the joy,
the pride
and the honor in growing yourown food.